so like favors men really so it's how  it's a bit unfair to just say how does  Okay can I can I have an example how how  does society favor men well like the  high paying jobs I know you're gonna say  women don't want to do the the high  paying jobs but most of the high paying  jobs they favor men like a woman has to  work most ten times let me ask you a few  questions those roles let me let me ask  you a question  um the NBA it's it's mostly it's mostly  it's like what 60 70 black roughly do  they discriminate against Asians there's  like no Asians in the NBA oh so you're  saying they're better no no no no no I'm  saying does the NBA discriminate against  Asians there are very few Asians in the  NBA what I'm saying is in any group you  you're never going to find true equality  when of outcome because different groups  like different things